[Music]
if you have a question or a comment for
our podcast give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at theminimalists.com
we have a question today from abel in
new jersey i have two storage units
filled with stuff
and i'm about to move into a new
apartment
what is the best way to start off my new
life and my new apartment with a
minimalist
point of view so julia this is another
problem that we have our homes become so
over abundant with stuff that we seek
out other areas to hide our clutter now
i don't know about abel specifically
maybe she is moving and she's moved all
of her things into storage that's one
way to do it and now she's saying i want
to extract the things that add value to
my life bring it into my new minimalist
home
so i'm avoiding the clutter up front and
bravo if that's the case or if you're
like many people who just store a lot of
things you're like my former self
i ran out of space in my basement my
attic my closet etc and so hey i know
what i'll do i'll spend 200 bucks a
month on more
space yeah now i will say this there are
times where it makes sense to have a
storage unit yeah and so i'm not against
storage units by and large i mean it
doesn't make sense to be completely
expensive not binary yeah absolutely
right the storage units become a problem
when they allow us to hide even more
clutter when they lose their function
and we're holding on to more of our
horde i i need excess space for this
excess stuff for clutter if there is
clutter in the storage unit then it is a
problem well what is clutter clutter is
merely something that gets in the way it
could physically get in the way but
we've gotten it out of the way because
we put in a storage locker but now maybe
it's still getting in the way
financially you're spending more money
on that storage unit it's getting in the
way emotionally or psychologically
because you're thinking about that stuff
that's out there and so how would you
talk to someone like abel julia who
where she wants to start this new
minimalist life
she's going into a new home a blank
slate
where does she start that's so exciting
first of all to begin with like when i
think about an empty space i get really
excited
even when i work in homes that are not
empty i always empty the space so we can
reimagine what it can become
so i love that first of all and if it is
the first scenario that you were talking
about of
she's temporarily placing her belongings
there because she just moved i guess
then in that case this is the perfect
time to declutter um i wouldn't say i'm
anti-storage unit always but i am most
of the time if the purpose is just to
stuff clutter in there because you ran
out of room in your home
so i think moving is always a great time
to reevaluate your belongings and if she
really wants to start a minimalist home
in this new space let's try to not need
those storage units anymore i would
empty them see what she really needs and
everything else potentially should go
why keep those storage units any longer
i can think of so many other uses for
that money than storing that stuff um if
it i don't know if she also has a home
full of things on top of the storage
units too if that were the case i would
really ask her when was the last time
she ever needed to go into those storage
units to access any of those things um
what are those types of things too it
may be things that are from
deceased relatives that she doesn't want
to deal with
and so this could be an opportunity to
work with an organizer to finally decide
i'm gonna go through these things and
make some decisions on them this is
similar to my own personal story i
didn't have a storage unit but i had
been moving around apartments all over
la for many years and we didn't have a
garage we didn't have a storage unit
either so i had probably 10 boxes large
tubs of my grandmother's belongings she
died in 98. so it took me until 2020 to
let it go so i like sharing this because
it was not easy for me to let go either
somehow my boyfriend now husband
allowed me to
carry this stuff everywhere and have it
shoved in our closets but eventually um
as i was decluttering my belongings is
the last thing that i dealt with enough
was enough and even for me just having
that open space in the garage and a few
of her items are now displayed in my
home office i see them every day instead
of having them stuffed in the garage or
the storage unit it's such a better way
to honor her memory yeah and and
everything so i don't know the contents
of what's in that storage unit but i
would want to know more about that
and
this is the great a great opportunity
that's that's what i would say to
someone who wants to move into a new
home and potentially just let it all go
yeah it is a great opportunity i'm
thinking if if i was able i would
like bring over the bare minimum
and then like i would test that out for
30 days and like see how my life felt
and if i'm like oh man like i really
need some of that stuff in the storage
unit or what then i would like bring
some stuff in kind of slowly
um but that's a process like that's not
easy it's simple but it's not very easy
to do that because you're making trips
back and forth like moving sucks in
general let alone like if you have to
make trips back and forth from your
storage unit uh in the first three
months like that's gonna add more stress
so
i think like yeah hiring a professional
organizer might be a good idea for abel
because maybe they can kind of help her
set it up a little bit better rather
than like spending months of like going
back and forth i don't know
i uh personally i would go back and
forth but again that's i'm always i go
the extreme route all the time anyway
well yeah and this is you're forcing
yourself into something that any move is
an extreme thing right moving all of the
possessions you've accumulated over the
last 20 30 40 50 60 70 years
that's an extreme thing even if you
don't own much i you know i moved
recently and a friend texted me and she
was like hey how'd the move go i'm like
it's simple i'm a minimalist but it
doesn't mean that i enjoy doing it even
if you're a minimalist it's still a
relatively extreme thing to have to do
to fill your car with all of your
possessions
you can organize it and reorganize it
yeah it's extreme right so it wasn't as
ryan said it wasn't easy but it was
simple relatively speaking now what
you're talking about ryan is sort of a
hybrid version of your packing party
yeah really yeah where instead of
unpacking everything in your home you're
leaving in a storage unit you're going
to get it as you need it and it's
important to set up some boundaries
there and one of those boundaries might
be hey i'm going to bring things in
slowly over the course of 21 days or one
month or two months i wouldn't go much
further than that certainly not farther
than 90 days for me because then you
have the seasonality rule right and then
i would find what boundaries work for
you able you can download our free ebook
it's called 16 rules for living with
less it's the minimalist rule book over
at theminimalists.com rulebook we'll put
a link to that in the show notes as well
or if you'd like the audiobook version
of that you can find that there as well
but abel i'd be happy to send you a copy
of that i also want to send you a copy
of our book everything that remains
because this was really the story of me
and ryan we started letting go of the
excess moving and we moved across the
country into montana everything i own
fit into my car
even that oversized lamp i don't know
why i tried to cram the damn lamp in the
car
i ended up not even needing it yeah but
um the truth is that even then there
were things that i was able to start
letting go of and i only realized that
when i set up some boundaries in my life
we talk about some of those boundaries
and everything that remains so i i did
have a storage unit when we moved out to
montana i had storage unit back in
dayton ohio because i didn't know if we
were going to be in montana you know i
didn't know how long
so uh went back to ohio i think after
being in montana for a few months and i
was like oh like i just need to get rid
of this stuff so i like created a little
craigslist ad did a yard sale got as
much money as i could but you know doing
the math i'm bringing this up for able
like doing the math if i would have kept
that storage unit for a year or two it
would have been sunk cost at that point
i just spent more money on that storage
unit than what was actually in that
storage unit but was worth in there so
able i would look at that too like how
long have you had it what's all that
stuff monetarily worth if it is worth
something great go ahead and sell it but
you actually might be saving money by
just like getting rid of that stuff i
also think it matters whether this is
only these are only able's possessions
or other people's possessions right
because i don't ever recommend letting
go of things
without other people's consent we don't
know that information yeah right it may
be other people's things that would want
to have a say in this yeah so right so
be considerate of other people's
possessions
yeah it's so it's so important because i
often get told that too like people will
say can i i give you consent throw away
all my husband's things like i'm not
going to do that without their
permission because they're never going
to trust me and this is also just not
good for your marriage to do these
things right
so just wanted to clarify that in my
advice so she said she's not a therapist
but you do play a really good therapist
i do so much mediation i never thought i
was gonna have to do that between
couples constantly where they will be
arguing in front of me about stuff and i
am that neutral third party where i make
things
things for them
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
you